[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
ich glaube ich eröffnet mal die kürbis
saison mit meinem neuen rezept und zwar
habe ich hier einen marshmallow
kürbiskuchen käsekuchen wollte
verschlagen das ist ein kürbiskuchen
innen drin habe ich eine bizkit masse
also ja sozusagen bizkit masse mit
kürbis dabei mit haselnüssen und
obendrauf so eine eiweiß sprits klausur
die vom geschmack her sehr an
marshmallows erinnert und die habe ich
dann auch noch flambiert und die torte
mit haselnüssen und kürbissen dekoriert
die torte ist wirklich super einfach in
der herstellung macht aber optisch finde
ich schon was her und fast vor allem in
die herbstliche zeit vielleicht sogar zu
halloween können euch mal überlegen so
eine torte zuzubereiten und ich würde
sagen wir starten direkt mal mit dem
teig und hier vorne stehen die zutaten
für den teig brauche ich einen kürbis
ich habe jetzt hier in hokkaido und
davon brauche ich 450 gramm 4 1 eigelb
150 gramm zucker etwas vanille extrakt
eine prise salz 100 gramm haselnüsse 175
gramm mehl einen teelöffel backpulver
einen halben teelöffel zimt und eine
unbehandelte orange also starten wir
jetzt mit dem teig dafür muss ich jetzt
erst einmal die rate mal ihr könnt
natürlich auch gemahlene haselnüsse
kaufen aber frisch gemahlen schmecken
sehr einfach viel viel besser
die haselmäuse kann ich jetzt einfach da
drin lassen und nehmen jetzt ihr diesen
aufsatz zum reiben und zwar brauche ich
den jetzt nämlich für den kürbis ich
habe jetzt hier einen hokkaido kürbis
den kann ich jetzt mit schale verwenden
was auch sehr gut schmeckt ist ein
muskatkürbis den gab's aber momentan
noch gar nicht aber den kann ich euch
auch sehr empfehlen den müsste aber auf
jeden fall schälen und jetzt brauche ich
hier von 450 km
das heißt ich schneide jetzt die stücke
weg für den aus und werden 450 gramm
abwägen und das dann einfach hier fein
reiben
[Musik]
mein körper ist muss ich sagen bin ich
ganz dankbar dass das jetzt das gerät
für mich übernommen hat den kürbis haben
mich schon sehr schwierig weil er
einfach sehr hart ist
jetzt kann ich den kürbis und die
haselnuss sich hier mal kurz stehen und
kann jetzt hier in die rührschüssel
bereits die eier reingeben das eigelb
das eiweiß brauche ich nämlich für den
guss also mag ich es ganz gerne wenn das
ei gibt dann auch mit verwertet wird
hier noch der zucker wandel extrakt und
salz rücken schlug mehr und die zutaten
werden jetzt für drei bis vier cremig
verrührt jetzt ist die eier zuckermasse
gut verrührt und jetzt kann ich hier die
trockenen zutaten verrühren
also mehl mit backpulver und sind ganz
gut früher und dann mit zum teig geben
und hier kommt jetzt auch der kürbis mit
rein und die haselnüsse und dann
natürlich auch noch der abrät von der
unbehandelten orange und auch der
orangensaft und wer möchte kann da auch
noch ein bisschen gewürze dazugeben zum
beispiel in diesen märkten ingwer also
das wird jetzt hier alles sehr gut dazu
passen sie sind muskat
[Musik]
wenn ihr die letzten jahre gut
aufgepasst habe dann wisst ihr dass die
moral absolut kein kürbismarkt aber ich
sage ihm später einfach nicht dass ein
kürbiskuchen ist und da bin ich mal
gespannt wie ihm der wie sage ich dann
wie eben der orange mit kuchen schmeckt
ich meine da wird ja schon mittel farbe
haben schon einmal gucken ich gut noch
wie es war packe aber ich werde nicht
verraten und guckt einfach was er zu dem
kuchen sagt niemand gestoppt jetzt
werden die zutaten einfach wird's gut
miteinander verrührt und wenn der teig
dann gut verrührt ist dann gebt ihr
ihnen eine backform die hat 24
zentimeter im durchmesser und hier fühle
ich jetzt den teig ein und kann ihn
schon verstreichen
ich streiche den teig auch immer gerne
am rand so ein bisschen hoch damit er
einfach ein bisschen gleichmäßiger
aufgehen kann
und jetzt kommt der kuchen in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 180 grad ober
unterhitze unter brauche also zwischen
35 und 40 minuten
ich werde auf jeden fall mit einem
zahnstocher die stäbchen probe machen
und dann den kuchen herausnehmen der
kürbis kuchen gebacken und ich habe ihn
auch abkühlen lassen jetzt kann ich mich
um die deko kümmern
ihr müsst ihr natürlich nicht machen
aber könnt ihr gerne ich werde jetzt
kleine kürbisse formen und dafür habe
ich jetzt hier 100 gramm weiße modell
schokolade bereits weit geknetet da
kommt ein stück rote modell schokolade
mit treiben und ein bisschen gelb damit
ein schönes orange entsteht
[Musik]
wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr das ganze
auch gerne aus marzipan machen wenn ihr
gerne marzipan möglich sind modelle
schokolade allerdings sei gut weil es
nach weißer schokolade schmeckt denn da
steckt auch 25 echte weiße schokolade
mit drin
und jetzt neben dem er ein kleines stück
ich hab da sitzen zwölf teile eingeteilt
und forme dieses jetzt zu einer kugel
zurück sahen ganz leicht flach und jetzt
könnt ihr mit einem stumpfen werkzeug
entweder marzipan messer oder einem
brotmesser zum beispiel vorher einmal
die mitte markieren und damit dem
stumpfen werkzeug einfach hier außen so
ein bisschen markieren
so sieht es dann aus muss auch nicht
perfekt sein denn ein kürbis ist nicht
perfekt und dann nehmt ihr einen spitzen
gegenstand kann auch eine löffelstiel
zum beispiel sein könnte es hier
eindrücken und aus schwarzer modelle
schokolade habe ich einfach ein ganz
kleines stück entnommen form dieses auch
zu einer kugel dann nämlich und das wird
dann dastehen wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr
den obenrum sie flach drücken und dann
einfach rein steckt schon habt ihr einen
fertigen kürbis die kürbisse sind jetzt
fertig geformt und jetzt zeige ich euch
noch die restlichen zutaten für den guss
brauche ich ein 1 2 esslöffel espresso
etwas man will extrakt 125 gramm
puderzucker und etwa 75 gramm haselnüsse
die habe ich bereits grob gehackt ich
habe jetzt hier schon mal einen topf mit
einer schüssel aufgestellt und das
wasser lasse ich jetzt auf kochen hat
sich hier und da habe ich was ein
wasserbad und weise für den eiweiß kurs
damit einfach das eiweiß nicht ganz rom
ist eben auf den kurven kommt sondern
ein bisschen erwärmt wird und in der
zeit kann ich schon mal den kuchen
nehmen und auf meine tortenplatte setzen
und den bug ring entfernen
[Musik]
das wasser kocht jetzt jetzt habe ich
die hitze ein bisschen reduziert einfach
damit nicht überkocht und jetzt kann ich
hier den puderzucker reingeben dass
vanille extrakt etwa zwei esslöffel
espresso den rest trinken und ein eiweiß
und die zutaten werden jetzt ein
bisschen verrührt und dann lasse ich das
hier einfach so etwa fünf minuten
erwärmen und wird dann kommen wasserbad
herunternehmen und in der küchenmaschine
einfach kalt rühren
ihr könnt aber natürlich auch ohne
küchenmaschine machen und dann mit dem
handrücken rest hat sind jetzt habe ich
die creme glatt gerührt und die
tortenplatte habe ich jetzt übrigens ein
bisschen abgedeckt mit backpapier damit
ich einfach die tortenplatte schön
sauber halten kann
und jetzt wird die creme also die eiweiß
fritz glaser sozusagen einfach auf die
torte gestrichen
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt die creme nicht ganz
glatt gestrichen sondern ein bisschen
strukturiert und jetzt könnt ihr sie
wenn ihr möchtet so hell lassen oder ihr
könnt auch ein bisschen flambieren das
mach ich gleich aber zuerst einmal
möchte ich noch die haselnüsse hier an
den rand kleben
[Musik]
man kann auch einen teller darunter
setzen muss man aber nicht wenn man
sauberer machen will
tschuldigung morath der darf später zu
hause
[Musik]
und ihr seid tortenplatte sauber aber
hier täglich aber egal macht nichts
jetzt bei flavia das muss nicht sein
aber ihr könnt gerne und dann einfach so
ein bisserl dem rand flambieren
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich noch die kürze drauf
setzen damit die torte fertig
[Musik]
jetzt kann frau wird hat sich ganz schön
finde an der klausur die trocknet ja so
ein bisschen
und dann ist die oberfläche so ein
bisschen knackigen unten dran ist wieder
schön ja sagte ich nicht aber es ist
feucht und was für eine schöne farbe
oder es nicht nur schöne farbe und da
der murat noch unterwegs ist wo das
natürlich probieren
[Musik]
also man kann mir gesagt noch mehr
gewürze mit rein geben würde ich
wahrscheinlich nächstes mal auch machen
leckerbissen irgendwie war es macht nur
noch oder aber auch so locker und nicht
so süß also ich hätte auch gedacht
vielleicht wegen der marshmallow
schlecht aber nein
der kuchen ist nicht so süß auf jeden
fall empfehlenswert macht ihn auf jeden
fall mal nach und falls ich das rezept
findet ihr es auch sein lieblings blog
de ich glaube ich muss ja noch ein paar
stücke abdrücken an das team
die neben wisse was mit nach hause und
ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachbacken wie gesagt probiert auch mal
mit dem muskatkürbis aus oder mit
anderen kürbissorten hokkaido war schon
mal sehr gut ich glaub schon mal
probieren muskatkürbis auf das hat sich
gut an
also viel spaß zum nachhaken und bis zum
nächsten mal und wer schnappt sich den
kürbis okay
[Gelächter]
[Musik]